Chancellor here we are in in a
department store and a lot of people
will be looking and wondering how safe
it is to get out there you're probably
looking at the economy and working out
you know is it going to restart when you
press the button what's your sense of
that particular question well we sent
out a plan some weeks ago for reopening
our country slowly getting our economy
going and we're executing to that plan
and the next stage of that plan is that
we're able to open retail shops like
this from next week and we can do that
because we set out five tests and we're
meeting those five tests thanks
everyone's hard work and I think that's
a good thing so yes we will get going
again and we slowly start to get our
lives back to normal but it won't be the
same as we've been walking around this
department store today you've seen all
the changes the signs the escalators the
screens so people can come back to
stores like this and shop in confidence
knowing that it is safe for them and
their families safe for the staff and I
think that's a very important first step
but these are deliberate these are
measured and these are careful steps and
why does that matter for the economy or
is it matter for unemployment why does
it matter for our livelihoods as we're
coming out of lockdown well I think we
we all want a healthy country we want to
be able to yes go back to work to the
jobs that we love we also want to see
our friends our families get our lives
back to normal and this is knocked down
in many ways has had lots of different
costs it's been necessary but your
people have not been able to go and get
the health care treatment that they need
children have not been at schools people
are suffering from increased mental
health or isolation and yes people as
you pointed out are losing their jobs
and that's going to have an impact not
just on their financial security but on
their long-term health as well so I
think you know it is important now that
we take our steps to rebuild our lives
and that do so in a careful and measured
way and that's what we're here today to
see and if we're not able to open up all
the shops open up all the pubs open up
all the hospitality what are the
consequences well if if you're asking
are there going to be severe
consequences from this knock down and
the answer is
yes and I've been very clear about that
it is gonna have an impact on people's
jobs and their livelihoods that weighs
very heavily and we need to prepare for
that for higher unemployment I think
first of all we should look at what
we've done and that's why I put in place
the furlough scheme which is now
covering almost nine million people
that's protected millions of jobs
through this crisis which is why it was
so important but looking forward you
know that yes there is gonna be hardship
ahead but I want people to know that I
will do absolutely everything I can to
make sure they have the skills the tools
and the support they need to get back
into hopefully an even better job as
quickly as possible you talk about a
plan are you happy with the way that
plan has unfolded with what has happened
in the UK over the course of the past
few months and the government's part in
it yes I'm I'm proud of what we've done
obviously we were faced with an
unprecedented isn't--it's that even
though we have you know one of the worst
death numbers death tolls in the world
you're still proud of your record uh I
would you know chief medical officers
has made this point many times and I
think he's right I think there will be a
time to look on all of this and reflect
and when it comes to numbers I think
that there are ways that he said are
only really possible to compare and
contrast after the fact when we have all
the data in so I think and there will be
a time to that and of course we should
we should do that and be so there's no
where well we should ignore the decision
it's all but I think in order to make
the comparisons that that you're you're
making that we don't have all the data
necessary to make those comparisons
accurately at this point but of course
we should make them no one is hiding
from that fact but if I look at the
measures that we've put in place in
particular around supporting people's
jobs their livelihoods through this
difficult time making sure that their
families have the support they need
making sure businesses you can stay
together
I do think those are significant steps
that have made a real difference to
people's lives and we do have a plan to
reopen are a country reopen our economy
now and we are making progress on that
plan I said that's what we're here today
to talk about so you can see the plan is
working and stores like this will be
open across the country from next week
that shows that we're making
and people should have confidence in
that plan but with the benefit of
hindsight you know could it have gone a
bit better well I've been very clear as
with other ministers been clear when
faced with something of this nature
completely unprecedented both in terms
of the scale and the speed in which it
was happening is it is it the case that
every single thing that we've got
perfectly right first time record of
course that's not going to be the case
and I think most people would look at
that and say you know fair enough but I
mean am I in even in my own economic
interventions I've been as you've known
you know our we've been iterating as we
go that speed and the scale of which
we've had to act has been unmatched
essentially in modern time so that means
that you know I've had to change things
as we go to make sure that the
interventions that we put in place are
getting to the people we want to get
support to and if that wasn't working
first time around and I've made changes
that I that I need to make okay finally
Chancellor obviously you'll have seen
the protests in this country and in the
u.s. about black lives matter
statues being pulled down when you see
that and when you kind of think through
your own experience what's your reaction
as a British Asian of course I know that
racism exists in our country and I know
people are angry they're upset and they
want to see change but what I would also
say is I change doesn't come about
through acts of vandalism or violence
that's not how you achieve real or
lasting change and what I would take a
moment to recognize is you know of
course our story as a country isn't
finished it's a work in progress and it
always will be and there's work to do
but I would take a moment to recognize
the enormous progress we've made as a
country from the time that my
grandparents first arrived here from the
time that I was born and grew up you
know the work that has happened in the
years before now has been tremendous and
everyone deserves credit for that but
that doesn't mean that there's not more
to do so of course there's more to do
and we will work hard at it
have you experienced racism yourself and
do you understand the anger a lot of
people from
absolutely I have I have growing up it's
things in a way that very few other
things have sung me but the things that
might have happened to me many years ago
when I was a kid I think are thankfully
things that would not happen to me today
and that's because of the progress that
our society in our country has made and
I it's something that I'm I'm very proud
of as a country but not not Fanning that
of course there's always work to do as I
said our story is not finished but
there's ways to bring about that change
and I have enormous respect for those
who are doing that in in a reasonable
way that it's not causing violence but
recognizing the issues at stake